E
PROBLEMS AS WE DISCOVER ON A
RECENT RAID, THAT UKRAINIANS --
THIS IS THE FORMER HEADQUARTERS
OF THE SUV YOU, THAT'S THE
SECRET POLICE EFFECTIVELY OF
UKRAINE.
NOW IT WAS HIT RIGHT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR WITH AN
AIR STRIKE, CLEARLY FROM THE
RUSSIAN PERSPECTIVE THIS IS AN
IMMEDIATE AS NECESSITY TO KNOCK
OUT --
THE CAPACITY HERE BECAUSE IT'S
FROM THIS LOCATION THAT THE
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE OPERATION
WOULD'VE BEEN ROUGH.
>> WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR HIM
FOR ABOUT FOUR DAYS, WE HAVE A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF HIS
ACTIONS.
THIS IS UKRAINE'S MOST
SECRETIVE FORCE, THE EQUIVALENT
OF THE FBI, AND THEN SAM.
SERGEI SAYS, WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
A PERSON WHO ACCORDING TO OUR
INTELLIGENCE IS COMMITTING A
CRIME, SIMPLY PUT THIS IS A
PERSON WHO TRANSMITS TO THE
RUSSIAN SIDE, THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY, INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LOCATION OF OUR UNITS.
THEIR SNATCHED CAME WITH ORDERS
TO GRAB AN ALLEGED RUSSIAN SPY.
THE SBU SAYS THE SPIES BEEN FED
A STREAM OF INFORMATION ON
TROOP MOVEMENTS AND DETAILS OF
TARGETS TO RUSSIA'S AIRCRAFT
AND ARTILLERY.
AND THIS REGIONALLY, AS WE USE
AS A CATCH AS ONE OR TWO AGENTS
RUN BY RUSSIA EVERY DAY.
AND TODAY'S SUSPECT IS BEING
WATCHED.
THERE HE GOES, HAVING A SMOKE.
ALL UNITS, GREEN PLANTS, BLACK
SWEATSHIRTS, 1000.
SPECIAL FORCES SWEETEN,
RESISTANCE --
TWO UKRAINIANS ARE ASKED TO
WITNESS THE INTERROGATION, WITH
OUR CAMERA PRESENT PROTOCOLS
ARE FOLLOWED TO THE LETTER.
HE'S TOLD WHY HE'S ARRESTED FOR
HIGH TREASON DURING MARTIAL LAW,
CONFESSES ON THE SPOT TO SPYING
HE SAYS THAT HE WAS ALLEGEDLY
REPUTED ON LINE, GETS ORDERS BY
MESSAGING APP BY SOMEONE CALLED
NIKOLAI.
THE SUSPECT SAYS THEY GOT ABOUT
$10 FOR IS ALLEGED BUYING,
WHICH INCLUDED THE LOCATIONS OF
UKRAINIAN MILITARY UNITS IN THE
TOWN.
ACCORDING TO AN ALLEGED
EXCHANGE BETWEEN HIM AND HIS
HANDLER, THE SUSPECT WAS
ARRESTED IN MID MISSION.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT PENALTY FOR
TRADERS HERE, BUT AS HE'S
DRIVEN THROUGH THESE
GAINESVILLE KNOW THAT IT'S
TRIED AND CONVICTED, YOU COULD
SPEND A LIFETIME ON BARS.
SERGEI'S HOMETOWN IS UNDER
CONSTANT RUSSIAN BOMBARDMENT,
FOR HIM THIS IS NO SMALL
VICTORY.
RUSSIA IS HITTING US WITH
MISSILES, ROCKETS, AREAS THESE
MISSILES HIT THE CORE NETS
WHICH ARE TRANSMITTED BY THESE
CRIMINALS.
PEOPLE DIE IN THESE ATTACKS,
SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS.
BUT, HE, ADDS MORE ATROCITIES
THE RUSSIANS COMMIT, THE HARDER
IT'S GETTING FOR THE CRIME ONE
TO RECRUIT LOCAL SPIES.
AND THE ANCHOR AFTER LOSING A
MARIUPOL, KHARKIV, YOU --
DONETSK, THESE ARE ALL CITY
WITH RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES
SPEAKERS PEOPLE WHO SPEAK
RUSSIAN AS ANOTHER YOUNG, THE
PEOPLE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN WITH
THAT WOULD BE SUPPORTERS AND
CONSTITUENTS, BUT THE LEVEL OF
VIOLENCE THAT HE HAS VISITED
UPON THIS REGION I THINK HAS
TURNED THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY EVEN OF THOSE WHO